all you got is the officer saying that
he raised the weapon
but the video clearly shows that he did
not
so you want us to believe the liars that
are las vegas metropolitan police
department
comments today from the mother of jorge
gomez the man who was shot and killed by
metro officers after a protest in
downtown last summer
this morning she gathered with members
of the community as county officials
held an hours-long fact-finding review
of evidence
in the deadly shooting good afternoon
and thank you so much for joining us at
four o'clock on this friday i'm kirsten
joyce
and i'm christian cassadas we'll have
much more on that fact-finding review
in just moments but first uh during
before
that hearing protesters were outside
making sure their chance for justice
was heard victoria saha spoke to several
protesters and she joins us now live
with reaction
protesters were gathered here at the
clark county commission building and
although things remained
calm their cries for justice and change
were loud and clear
justice for jorge gomez a mission
friends and family and several members
of the community
are fighting for 10 months later
protesters firmly believe
gomez did not deserve to be shot by
metro police officers
19 times they say he was running from
police
protesters are pleading for those four
officers involved to be held accountable
for killing gomez
i do hope that me and the other people
here today are heard and
some sort of steps aren't made towards
an arrest or an indictment or
at least a statement saying yeah he was
murdered enough is enough and that's the
biggest thing like people need to stop
getting away with murder
during the fact-finding review the
family attorney says it felt like gomez
was being pinned as a criminal because
unrelated marijuana charges from five
years ago were being brought up
now the family attorney says no matter
what happens the family will still
continue their
suit against metro police and of course
goldman's mother was very emotional
through all this
we'll hear from her more from her coming
up tonight at 5.
reporting live victoria saha 8 news now